I think the antifa story is so
interesting because
this is sort of the heaviest hit that
I've seen to antifa I mean Portland
cannot get their situation under control
and in contrast it's the same day that
we see the longest sentence hand down to
anyone involved in anything related to
January 6. I mean if you can't see that
the justice system has favorites I don't
know what we'll tell you uh I don't I
don't know
how people can have faith in any sort of
uh judicial branch of if state or
whatever or anything I mean the federal
government is sending thousands of
people they've charged thousands of
people I think it's a thousand 106 the
last doj number I saw uh in connection
January 6th uh 600 people at least have
been sentenced and in contrast you know
Justin Jones who's a state
representative in Tennessee got
reinstated after he led a you know
protest on the floor of the chamber that
disrupted official official proceedings